hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the key
themes in ryoga's letters to a young
poet is the dangers of convention of
allowing oneself to live a life to
engage in relations with others and
actions and words that are remaining at
a conventional level and this is
something that I think is just as
relevant today as it was in Rilke zone
time perhaps even more so given the
proliferation of the internet and you
know the ways in which we can reach
human beings across the world we cannot
get entirely away from convention I mean
we're using language to begin with and
we can't do something that's totally
original because we wouldn't even be
able to recognize it as such but
convention when it's relied upon as sort
of the the basis the criterion for what
is valuable for what is authentic what
is genuine leads us into some as Rilke
is going to talk about it some sterile
some lifeless even though there's life
there some some fundamentally hemmed-in
ways of existing and the other word that
he uses quite a bit superficial
you know meaning that we stay at the
level of the surface and we donut
descend into the depths where he thinks
the real action of life is not that
there is an action on the surface level
as well and what's publicly observable
but we need to have roots and
conventions keep us from having deep
roots they have their own little roots
that go you know to the surface deep but
they can't really withstand anything
that goes deeper than that and Rilke
talks about conventions in this work in
three main areas of life one is in art
his interlocutor mr. Campos sends him a
poem which Rilke responds to by saying
your poem I'm sorry just isn't very good
you don't have a style yet you are and
he's saying this without saying this in
these very words you're kind of
conventional you're just at that level
as a matter of fact avoid any sort of
reliance on you know conventions or
tropes or the what you think of poet
ought to be doing write about this
instead and so that's one main area
another that he discusses that
considerable length particularly in
letter 7 but in also a few other places
has to do with sexuality love relations
between men and women and Rilke says
that there's actually no area that's so
conventional as this the area that think
about this he's writing this you know a
little bit after the turn of the century
and he's writing as somebody who's part
of the European elite so he's quite
liberated person he's writing this as
somebody who sees all the possibilities
ahead and says yes many of them are
actually just new forms of convention
don't kid yourself and then finally he
talks in letter six about professions or
vocations mr. compost is a soldier and
Rilke is going
give him some advice about the
conventions that are involved in that as
a matter of fact in his final letter to
him he talks about you know his
interlocutor
he says I'm glad you have that firm
sayable existence within you that title
that uniform that service all that
tangible and limited world with a twitch
in such surroundings with such an
isolated and not a numerous body of men
takes on seriousness and necessity above
and beyond the frivolity and mere time
passing of the military profession so
he's saying you have gone beyond the
conventionality that is so dangerous in
the profession that you have selected
the convention that so many people
within your unit probably has to come to
so I have several different points that
I thought were really relevant that I
want to stress coming from different
letters one is he talks about this is a
really wonderful turn of phrase he talks
about conventions being established like
public shelters on this most dangerous
road and the dangerous road that he's
talking about there is love and
sexuality and this points toward
something quite central to conventions
why do we have conventions if they're
holding us back why don't we just get
rid of them well we do need them as a
matter of fact they allow us to you know
venture forth a little bit gained a
little confidence and then have
something we can go back to so think
about dating for example write a
convention that is you might say under
reconfiguration in the days of online
dating apps like tinder or you know
whatever else you want to bring up
Grindr bumblebee that bumblebee bumble
all these other plethora of things or
you can you know connect with people on
Facebook or Instagram or whatever those
are just right
with conventions people come in with
expectations that's why you can have
shows about dating where somebody can
deconstruct a date and say this one well
this didn't go well the criteria that
they're using are essentially for the
most part conventions right every once
in a while you'll see an original moment
arise during like holy crap something
happened on television that isn't just
canned crap but for the most part it's
conventions and why do we have these
established well somebody put up those
shelters and other people take you know
residents in them and word gets out and
pretty soon you know you have something
that people know about we could say the
same thing for conversations we could
say the same thing for politics we could
say the same thing for pretty much
anything even cooking you know oh the
recipe didn't turn out the right way
well there's there's an excuse for that
an excuse that you've heard somebody
else make so we have these conventions
and you know they do serve some sort of
purpose but we don't want to just live
in a public shelter do we we want to
venture out into the wide world and we
want to go down as he says this
dangerous road so you know he tells us
that again with sexuality no area of
human experience is so extensively
provided with conventions and this one
is and then he talks about it with
another metaphor there are life
preservers of the most varied invention
boats and water wings Society has been
able to create refuges of every sort for
since it preferred to take love life as
an amusement it also has to take an easy
form cheap safe and sure as public
amusements are he's writing this over a
century ago but it applies just as well
to our own time and we'll come back to
this question of Convention and in
sexuality in just a moment he also says
that every profession or life situation
is going to have some sort of convention
involved in it right so this is in
letter six he tell
that you know when you look at adults
you realize that their activities are
shabby that they're perfect their
vocations or professions are petrified
and no longer connected with life he
says why don't you adopt the viewpoint
of a child as if you were looking at
something unfamiliar out of the depths
of your own world from the vastness of
your own solitude which is itself work
in status and vocation he's suggesting
that you know we could have a vocation
of solitude or iDEN some kite another
very important real kata concept he goes
on and he says who says that you have to
have any attitude towards all these
things at all I know your profession is
hard and full of things that contradict
you and I first saw your lament and knew
that it would come because this is
something that happens over and over and
over again he says now that it has come
all that I can say to reassure you is to
suggest that perhaps all professions are
like that filled with demands filled
with hostility towards the individual
saturated as it were with the hatred of
those who find themselves mute and
sullen in an insipid duty the situation
you must live in now is not more
heavenly heavily burdened with
conventions prejudices and false ideas
than all the other situations and if
there are some that pretend to offer a
greater freedom there is nevertheless
none that is in itself vast and spacious
and connected to the important things
that the truest life seems to consist of
and I'll mention as somebody who teaches
philosophy and studies philosophy for a
living that it he's really correct about
this it's not just that you know within
the creative world of artists there turn
out to be all these conventions of the
art world it's that way in the world of
philosophy as well you'd be surprised
how many of my peers are creatures of
pure convention they seem to be doing
something very you know original and
interesting and creative and open-minded
but they're all open-minded in the same
way and they use the same book
AB you Larry for it and it changes from
place to place and it changes from
decade to decade as the fads
you know proliferate but it's still the
same thing I mean you could think about
cultural stuff as well you know you we
can make fun of people for being woke
right but woken us has turned into its
own forms of conventions and even the
people who criticize woke nests do it
primarily in a conventional way why so
that they can reach a larger audience
who can respond to them immediately and
we don't have to do a lot of thinking a
lot of reflection a lot of dialoguing a
lot of thinking things through and
mulling things over and genuinely
communicating with one another this is a
problem in every profession this is a
problem in every area of life now coming
back to the sexuality part
Rilke talks about young people not
having fully developed enough and he
says when they try with the best of
intentions to escape the convention that
is approaching them for example marriage
they fall into the clutches of some less
obvious but just as deadly conventional
solution why because everything around
them is convention whenever people act
out of a prematurely fused muddy
communion every action is conventional
why because they don't know any better
they haven't developed the capacity to
respond in a more creative authentic way
to each other he says every relation
that such confusion leads to has its own
convention somebody else has already
done that probably written about it on a
website or saying a song about it you
know think about how people regulate
their their sex life and their love life
according to love songs those are
primarily conventions and if you try
something different you switch the
channel and get a different song on well
that's a convention too you know
you don't want to get married you just
want to have hookups that's a convention
you want to reject you know the hookup
culture and say you know I need
something that's more substantive there
was this very funny movie back in the
1980s called casual sex that had you
know a few stars and like Rob Lowe and
Demi Moore and and one of the characters
actually said I just want to find
somebody that I can have meaningful sex
with and at the time that that was sad
people are like oh yeah you know that
seems to be something unconventional
that was already conventional at the
time that that actress said it and the
audience nodding their heads in there
were just acting out of convention as
well it's very difficult to move out of
that Roka goes on and says even
separating would be a conventional step
an impersonal accidental decision
without strength and without fruit and
he tells us that we're in a special time
where the goal is to consider the
relation of one individual to a second
individual and to live out such
relationships without some sort of model
in front of us now does that mean that
like you have to like be even further
beyond convention know you would be
living within the heart of conventions
but you would live in a very different
way without buying into them entirely as
other people do and this is another key
point Broca thinks that convention
stands in the way of developing
individuality and what he calls solitude
I'm Tom kite which is a central concept
in this entire work and by doing that it
stands in the way of the possibility not
of only being on our own but of having
more genuine relations to other people
to nature and to what he calls things so
I'm going to give you just a few
examples of how this could stand in the
way I mentioned in the passage that I
read that he thinks that there are many
people who are living lives that are
essentially convention and they're
hostile to the individual in part
because they can't be individuals in the
full sense and
they want everybody else to have the
same sort of restricted world that they
do they may actually get quite angry at
somebody who doesn't fit into one form
of convention or another he also talks
about irony and this is in letter two he
says don't let yourself be controlled by
it
especially during on creative moments
when you're fully creative try to use it
as one more way to take hold of life use
purely irony can be pure but if you feel
yourself becoming too familiar with it
if you're afraid of this growing
familiarity then turn to great and
serious objects in front of which it
becomes small and helpless turn towards
other things why because irony has the
tendency to lapse into its own sort of
conventionality doesn't it and we live
in an age of irony so this can actually
be a major issue for us another thing
that he talks about this is in letter
five he says that you know one of the
things that you want to attain is a holy
individual relation to sex one that is
not influenced by convention and custom
and then you no longer have to be afraid
of losing yourself and becoming unworthy
of your dearest possession he talks
about bodily delight there and he says
that most people have muddied bodily
delight into something else because of
conventions we want to be able to have
an individual relation as an individual
to the things that matter most in life
and so that would include what our book
profession or vocation or even job
happens to be it would include sex and
love and it would include not just art
but any sort of creative activity that
we are involved in convention stands in
the way of these if we allow it to and
the last thing that I'll say is one
cannot simply reject convention
immediately it requires some growth
within the depths on one's own part to
be able to go beyond it
you